any father that's thinking about
spending a thousand dollars to take his
son to watch LeBron play to watch uh
Curry play to watch you know anybody
play except for a couple players that
won't miss a game anybody that's
thinking about spending a thousand
dollars there is a high likelihood that
your favorite player may not play on
that day why the hell would you take
your kid with the thousand dollars that
you have to go watch the game knowing
the best player may not play in a season
game it's a product today there's better
products than the NBA to consider
playoffs different story but season I
think NBA's a is not a good product
today
foreign
[Music]